You've seen that supervised machine
learning algorithms can classify your data.
Unsupervised machine learning
algorithms can cluster your data.
Now let's look at an entirely different set of
algorithms based on conditional probability.
Say you're looking to see how one thing impacts
the probability of another thing happening.
The most popular algorithm for this type of
analysis is called the Bayesian algorithm
based on the Bayes' theory of statistics. Naive
Bayes is one of the most popular Bayesian machine
learning algorithms. It's called naive because it
assumes that all of the predictors are independent
from one another. Naive Bayes is mostly used
for binary or multiclass classification.
Let's go back to our animal shelter in Chicago.
Imagine that we wanted to classify all the dogs
in the shelter based on their different
breeds. Remember that there are hundreds of
different dog breeds. On top of that, most
dogs would be a mixture of several breeds.
Let's look at this problem using a
naive Bayes machine learning algorithm.
To start, let's create three classes of dog
breeds. We'll use terrier, hounds, and sport dogs.
Now, for each of these classes, we'll have
three predictors. Let's use hair length, height,
and weight. Remember that some of the predictors
will be closely autocorrelated. A tall dog is more
likely to be heavier. But naive Bayes considers
each one of these predictors independently.
Remember, that's why it's called naive.
Once you have your classes and predictors set up,
then the naive Bayes machine learning algorithm
starts with something called class predictor
probability. This is when it looks at each of
the independent predictors and tries to create a
probability that the dog belongs in each class.
Let's see what happens when you're
trying to identify an unknown dog.
The first predictor you look at is hair length.
The machine learning algorithm can check the
probability of a dog with this hair length
belonging to any of the three classes. It finds
that a dog with this hair length has a 40% chance
of being a terrier, a 10% chance of being a hound,
and a 50% chance that it's a sport dog. The
next thing you check is the unknown dog's
height. Again, naive Bayes doesn't correlate
the dog's hair length with the dog's height.
It looks at this predictor independently and tries
to calculate the probability that this unknown dog
will belong to each class. So, again, it looks
at the training data and finds that there's a 20%
chance that it's a terrier, a 10% chance that it's
a hound, and a 70% chance that it's a sport dog.
The final thing you want to check
is the unknown dog's weight.
This might seem like a strange predictor
because it's closely related to height.
But remember, the naive Bayes is evaluating the
probability of each predictor independently.
It looks at the training data and finds
there's a 10% chance it's a terrier,
a 5% chance that it's a hound, and
an 85% chance that it's a sport dog.
You now have this table with the unknown
dog's class predictor probability.
If you look at it, you can see that the dog is
probably a sport dog. But remember, most machine
learning problems are dealing with terabytes
or even petabytes of dog data and is trying to
classify millions of unknown dogs.
To classify your dog, you might want to use
something called the weighted multiplication
function. Since this is a weighted function, the
first thing you want to do is create a weight.
It's here you'll decide which one of
your predictors is the most predictive.
You can pick this weight by looking at the
training data. You can also tweak it if it
improves your accuracy. Here we'll use a weight
of three for hair and two for weight and height.
For the weighted multiplication function, take
the predictor and multiply it by your weight.
When you add up the predictors for
hair length, height, and weight,
you can see that the second unknown
dog is most likely a sport dog.
It's less likely that it's a terrier
and very unlikely that it's a hound.